week 7 2020 nfl season you get the first
pick
show me something kyle allen because if
you don't show me something
against the league's most putrid defense
the dallas cowboys on sunday
it's not going to be very long before
alex smith
you're gonna you already feel the hot
breath of alex smith down your neck
alex smith is gonna be replacing you in
the lineup you
have a must-win game
this one is a low bar but show me
something josh allen after a couple of
games that surely rattled his confidence
this is his opportunity to remind us all
of the levels at which he had progressed
before the bills ran into the titans and
the chiefs
six days apart this is your chance to
get
right again this is your chance to go
out and have a big game and we need a
big game to have our faith restored
in one of the guys who was in the mvp
conversation not that long ago and could
still pull his way back into it and the
process starts on sunday peter
show me something michael thomas and it
isn't
just show me 10 catches for 160 yards
despite a gimpy ankle and hamstring no i
don't
i don't even know if he's gonna play you
know
because obviously they added the
hamstring injury to his uh
uh to his portfolio this week but
show me that you're willing to be you're
willing
to say hey listen i screwed up my fault
you should have come down on me like a
ton of bricks for punching somebody
uh and so i'm gonna be a really good
teammate
so show me something michael thomas be a
great teammate
you know i usually would stay away from
that same game
but show me something teddy bridgewater
going back to new orleans where he was
5-0 last year
with an offense that they run in new
orleans against the defense he knows
pretty well
from practice right we talk about how
well
that you know the saints would maybe
know him and how well the saints know
joe brady the guy who was there
as part of that offensive coaching staff
but brady combined with bridgewater
going into that superdome fans will be
there
teddy proved to us that it wasn't just
you were in the right place at the right
time but you still have it i think he
does
this is his opportunity to show us that
he'd go back there beat his old team
and really establish the panthers as
potential contenders in 2020 peter
show me something cam newton so
all cam newton has on sunday
is the weight of the
most storied accomplished sports
franchise
of the 21st century on his shoulders
that's all he has but in reality
what you're seeing is what the patriots
gave up
you know to to basically give tom brady
a couple more years
so you've seen what the patriots gave up
so
the guy who was supposed to be the heir
is coming in and your playoff hopes
in to a large degree are on the line you
know the next
two weeks san francisco and buffalo and
and so you have got to show
that this signing by the new england
patriots even though
even though you know we all know that
your weaponry
is not good we know that but you have
got to take this team on your shoulders
and beat a good san francisco team on
sunday in foxborough
show me something guy who just beat cam
newton and that would be drew locke
because you got patrick mahomes
coming to town and we talked earlier
about
the interceptions thrown late in the
game that gave the patriots a chance to
maybe come back
and win dru lock is going to have to be
on his game he's going to have to throw
touchdowns not set up field goals he's
going to have to avoid
throwing interceptions and you know
peter between the durability issues
and the interceptions that maybe does
become enough to get
john elway to say okay we'll continue
the search for the next franchise
quarterback
we believe i know i believe it could be
locke but i'm concerned about the
injuries
i'm definitely concerned about the
interceptions i become less concerned if
he could go toe-to-toe with patrick
mahomes at home
and find a way to win the football game
show me something jimmy garoppolo you've
got three months to show
everybody that you're the quarterback of
the long-term future for the san
francisco 49ers
you go back to where you were birthed
in the nfl you've got to take the
emotion
of that of looking across the sidelines
and seeing your mentor josh mcdaniels
seeing the guy who did you a solid bill
belichick
seeing those people who you've got great
affection for
and you come back to this place you got
to take the emotion out of it
you've got to be clinical in this game
this
is a i'm not saying it's a must-win for
san francisco
but in a division as good as the nfc
west
you need to win games on the road
against teams
that are wounded tigers the new england
patriots are a wounded tiger
this was the most seamless fourth round
we've ever had peter i love how you went
straight into it let me go ahead and
finish round four
and today's draft by saying john gruden
show me something john gruden don't just
show me that you can beat the tampa bay
buccaneers or at least you can be
competitive
show me you can control your damn team
show me you can get your guys to apply
with the coach at 19
yes yes show me that you're not going to
be the guy who presides over an outbreak
that derails our season
for all that tough talk we heard from
him and you know i've said in the past
and i'm not saying it now but maybe i am
gruden's got a little bit of that fake
tough guy element to him
and we heard him blustering about cover
19. we got to go beat kova 19 and all
this stuff
well then go do it because right now
coach cover 19 is kicking your ass
and it's on you when your team when your
players
fail to comply with the protocols that
means you're not doing
enough of that knock on wood if you're
with me bs
to get them to buy in so worry a little
bit less about the x's and o's
and worry a little bit more about covid
and maybe your team will be able to play
all of its games this year but show me
show me that you're willing to do it
because look the players
are the ones who think they're
impervious to this they're the ones who
need to be coached to take it seriously
and it's
obvious it became obvious when we saw
those guys at that event
three weeks ago with no masks confined
space too many people in one room
it became obvious then and it's obvious
now that he's not doing a good enough
job
at getting his guys to understand what
they need to do what we need to do is
take a break we'll wrap up mike
go ahead now just very quick
he showed at the time when they didn't
nip it in the bud after that appearance
that tells me a lot that if people are
being laxed with their mass
after that that tells me that john
gruden
is not doing nearly a good enough job
with his team
it's not the infection control officer
it's not mike mayak it's not mark davis
it's the head coach every day haranguing
his team
telling them to stay in line over this
gruden
in the immortal words of melania trump
be better and and we know
we know he knows how to harangue all we
have to do is talk to chris sims about
the years that he was harangued by
about far less important things than
keeping a deadly virus out of your
building
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports